[Music]  my name is sean hannity and i've been at  fox from day one  october 1996.  my first love was radio i never imagined  myself being on tv and it was certainly  a learning curve for me i'm sean hannity  she is the politician who has taken  america by storm it changed my life  in every way imaginable i say what i say  loudly i say it proudly and i say it  unapologetically we're the usa we can do  better my father died  six months after i started a fox and the  one thing  my father would say to me where did this  come from and i said i don't know  it's in there somewhere my message to  the people is thank you this is an honor  to do what i do every day and  what i can do in return is just my very  very best and that effort that passion  from day one has never left me